fighting in northern ethiopia threatens
to
tip that country into civil war the
conflict comes down to a power struggle
between prime minister
abby ahmed and the leader of the
rebellious
tigray region other countries are being
drawn into the conflict raising fears of
destabilization across the region
tens of thousands of civilians have fled
the fighting across a border river into
sudan and tigray's leader has admitted
ordering a rocket attack on neighboring
eritrea as
a close ally of ethiopia's federal
government
let's go now to ethiopia's capital addis
ababa
and talked to journalist samuel
gateshead samuel
ethiopia's president abby athman says
he's confident
that his forces can restore order in
tigray province
what what's he up against militarily
uh well ethiopian prime minister to be
exact uh he
um he is the determination is there and
the support is there
uh he has already called the tigrai
government illegal
and appointed a new administration
and the ethiopian army is one of the
most
resourced and uh in the region
and so the determination is there but
the conflict is
really beginning to affect thousands of
ethiopians
who are pushed not just to sudan but
anywhere even coming to
the region and as you mentioned the un
uh has already said about 25 000
ethiopians have moved to
sudan but that's an official number
there are more
thousands of them that haven't been
accounted so it's a disaster that's
just amazing so if i understand you
correctly
we're looking at a very formidable
military force in tigre
province why would the tigrai rebels
though
launch an attack on their northern
neighbors in eritrea when their dispute
is primarily
with prime minister abe and the central
government in ethiopia
you know the tpnf was in government for
27 years uh
when ethiopia and eritrea had a war um
it was a tpn left government that you
know that had a
conflict with the uh eritrea so the
european government
under the president isaiah safforki has
taken that to heart
uh and he's always wanted to
you know pay uh what uh he felt was an
invest
invasion of uh his nation so when abi
came to power in 2018
when he tried to bring peace between
ethiopia and eritrea
the tplf was never happy they they felt
uh
abby was creating a partnership with a
foreign nation that was
against the interests of tplf and that's
how the conflict begun
simon just uh very briefly what about
the the
uh humanitarian implications of this for
the region you mentioned as refugees
how serious is it
i mean so far 25 000 people official
number of 25 000
have moved to the sudan there are more
that haven't been accounted for
uh you know the people that have uh
moved to the sudan are telling us
that older people young children have
been left behind
the ngos have been pushed out of the
tigray region
they've been looted by the tpnf soldiers
they claimed so it's a disaster and it's
not just within ethiopia the conflict
it's not just way territory
but it will soon come to the european uh
nations
very soon samuel thank you very much
that was journalist samuel getachu
in addis ababa
thank you